حرب غير مسبوقه في السماء
العاصمه الاوكرانيه تتعرض لهجمه صاروخيه
وصفت بالاكثر تعقيدا من جهات مختلفه
وبصواريخ قالت السلطات الاوكرانيه انها
باليستيه ومجنحه وفرط صوتيه تعاملت معها
الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه ما احدث
انفجارات هزت ارجاء المدينه
اطلق العدو صواريخ باليستيه من ست طائرات
استراتيجيه وهذا النوع من الطائرات يحمل
الصواريخ كنجال الجويه وقد اطلقت سته منها
باتجاه العاصمه ودمرناها كما اطلق العدو
من البحر الاسود تسعه صواريخ كروز من نوع
كاليبر باتجاهات مختلفه ودمرت ايضا
يلملم الاوكرانيون في كييف ما تبقى لهم من
شعور بالامان بعد انفجارات سببت اضرارا في
احياء مختلفه من العاصمه يعتقدون انها
ربما كانت اكثر فتكا لولا اعتراضها
استيقظنا على اصوات انفجارات قويه جدا هذه
حاله صعبه فرضها علينا من كانوا يوما
جيراننا لكنني كلي ثقه بالله وبالدفاعات
الجويه لجيشنا التي تحمينا
هو الهجوم الثامن خلال هذا الشهر فقط في
اطار وتيره متسارعه من ضربات تترك اثارها
على السكان حتى عند تصدي لها تقول السلطات
الاوكرانيه ان دفاعاتها الجويه اسقطت معظم
الصواريخ التي هاجمت العاصمه بما فيها
صواريخ كينجال الفرط صوتيه ما حد من حجم
الاضرار روايه تشير حسب متابعين الى
فاعليه عمل قوتها الجويه التي زودت
بمنظومات دفاعيه غربيه متعدده
على اطراف العاصمه تستعد وحده الدفاع
الجوي هذه لمهمه جديده تحسبا لاستهدافات
اخرى لا سيما بالمسيره الانتحاريه التي
يحاولون رصدها واسقاطها بمنظومات مختلفه
كسلاح ستنجر الامريكي المزدوج هذا الذي
تسلموه منذ بدايه الحرب حيث تقول القوات
الجويه ان وحداتها المختلفه تمكنت من رفع
مستوى دقه الاصابات الى 90 بالمئه بدلا من
اربعين بالمئه قبل الحرب اعمل على سلاح دي
ام اس ستينجر وهو يحمل صاروخين مضادين
لطائرات نستخدمه لاسقاط الصواريخ والمسيره
الانتحاريه بشكل مستمر وهو يقوم بدور فعال
في عملنا